they're going to keep coming after him
and why are they going to keep coming
after him because now he's hitting biden
and the biden thing is crumbling and why
is it mostly crumbling well it's mostly
due to the bad policy it's not even the
dementia right it's not even the
cognitive stuff it's mostly because the
policies are bad if he was slurring all
his words if he was unable to read the
teleprompter if he was falling down the
stairs and wandering free range out
there on the grass when they let him off
the helicopter and couldn't find the
door if all of that was still happening
if he was taking orders from the easter
bunny all of the stuff that we keep
seeing happening if the country was
basically in good shape nobody would be
complaining and i would be complaining
far less honestly if he was just a sort
of old
losing it buffoon it would be kind of
funny but if the country was working out
it's like all right we'll move on and
talk about other things it's the
coupling of both of those things that is
the problem but it's mostly the fact
that the economy
and the energy sector and everything
else is really really struggling and ron
desantis is calling him out on it we
want to get your thoughts as well on gas
prices hitting another record high
hitting everybody in their pocketbook
every part of uh
every state every business uh is
affected by the
this administration seems to not have
any proactive solutions to it other than
blaming putin
they're the cause of a lot of it joe
biden came into office and declared war
on american energy we were energy
independent for the first time in my
life uh when he came into office he had
sweeping executive orders to try to
kneecap american energy production and
look this is a global market it's not
just the us but he has made it way worse
here in this country and they will not
reverse course this is just a religion
for them to be attacking energy
production in the united states and
people are paying at the pump like never
before it's hammering blue-collar people
working people but as you said it
impacts everything in the economy
because when those energy prices are
skyrocketing transportation the cost of
goods and so you're seeing that as the
number one driver in the inflation we
see also the fact that they printed
trillions of dollars that we didn't have
but those two factors have created a
really a hellish scenario and now we're
on the precipice if we're not already in
a formal recession maybe that won't
happen now but i think everyone's
looking at it and say under biden with
his policies he's going to plunge this
country into a recession
all right so clear and honest truthful
refreshing to hear so what's happening
well you've got desantis's political
sanity and rationality and that's
coupled with the craziness of the left
so what does that add up to if you take
those two things you put a plus sign
between the two of them and then you put
an equal sign well what do you got you
got a gold mine on the other side for
conservatives for republicans to really
turn this thing around and that's why
i'm feeling good about the world right
now because opportunity is right in
front of us but we have to grab it we
can't just sit there with it